straight to the Indian capital whether
Prime Minister that Narendra Modi and
russia's President Vladimir Putin have
signed a contract for the delivery of
the s400 air defense systems with New
Delhi ultimately defying threats of
possible sanctions from Washington let's
cross live to the Indian capital now RT
is Akash down of joining us here on the
program ie go to one aspect of the
meeting that was not only evident but
also remarked upon several times by both
leaders was their mutual respect and
close friendship and what other
highlights of the meeting have we also
heard about
well Rory in fact Vladimir Putin and his
Indian counterpart indeed right now
right here and they're expected expected
to pass right behind me well any minute
now they're following their program but
right now everything they're doing is
sort of on a light note on the lighter
side of things and if I may say so
because they've arrived here after
signing a batch of documents and they're
well if I were to list you all areas of
cooperation and all aspects that Russia
and India have discussed today well
really it would take too much of your
and my time really but the biggest thing
is the India is India purchasing the
s400 anti-missile defense system it's
not just it's not just a buying about
buying Russian weapons and India
expanding its defensive capabilities
it's India giving a political statement
it's India making a very bold
geopolitical move because obviously it's
not just regional rivals who may be on
edge right now because of the
acquisition it's also the United States
because Washington has a problem every
time anybody looks to buy and were
indeed buys Russian weapons for example
last time when China did that both the
same anti-missile defense system and
some fighter jets to go with it
they were slammed with sanctions
Washington imposed sanctions on them
which well caused fury in Beijing now
India is doing the same and it's doing
in defiance of the of the previous
warnings it has already heard from
Washington the Pentagon one of the
generals has said that the option of
sanctions is indeed on the table and
that well if India follows through with
the purchase then it'll be up to the US
president to decide whether or not to
impose penalties so now they've done it
and so it is interestingly it's Russia
and China excuse me of course Russia and
India doing business but really it's
fair to say that the ball is now in
America's court all right artoo you
gotta turn off their live in New Delhi
thank you
you